[Music]
you there's a scene in this movie where
there is a a threesome takes place with
you Sofia Vergara and John Turturro and
I'm told that John Turturro wrote did he
write this scene or do you direct this
scene he did both
he wrote it I figured he was just
sounded so suspicious to me
I've got an idea you and Sofia Vergara
with me in bed right I think the whole
movie was kind of that yeah yeah but if
the movie I have to say the movie is
really great you know I've done some
real but I called him like I see him
yeah but this went really great it's
really great and it's so charming and
she's so lovely in it too and and Liev
Schreiber and Vanessa parodies
everybody's so wonderful in it and John
is great and Woody Allen what's all
about Woody Allen because Woody Allen
plays more or less he plays and a pimp
he plays John Turturro spin yes which if
you if you ever think of casting a pimp
and you think of who have you last on
the list right it would be woody Oh be
me then Woody Allen probably and maybe
Bob's Big Boy like the third I don't
know but that's just such an unlikely
unlikely couple and that's what makes it
so sweet and it's it's really really
it's actually really lovely and it's
these women who are kind of you know
lost and and he's he heals them in this
very it's really charming it's really a
nice movie it's really it's a very nice
date movie it's it's really a sweet
movie can I ask you I know that I auntie
directed the menage a toy in his
underpants
yes oh and oh I love that he's in the
menage tois
and he's directing it at the same time
yes so he's with you guys rolling around
and then he's running out and checking
the camera and then getting back yeah
uh-huh
that's a nice job
Woody Allen speaking of jobs wasn't
Woody Allen one of the first people to
give you a job to give you a job let us
start us memories darkness memories and
I've had the pleasure of working with
him many times in my career and he's
he's such an excellent director he's
such a lovely man and he's been very
kind to me over the years I love working
with him the first that parts artists
memories the way I heard it sort of I
don't know if it's a myth or not you
weren't even supposed to have that part
but the person who was supposed to play
that part
didn't come didn't show up no I was cast
as an extra and I was sitting there with
a lot of other extras reading a book and
and the the first ad came down and said
you know the person who was supposed to
play his part didn't come today would
you like to play the part and I was like
sure when he was like now oh my god and
he said Woody's gonna come down and talk
to you about it and he came down and I
was reading this book and so he talked
to me about my book and for like about a
half an hour which was already for me
really exciting and overwhelming and
then he gave me the part and so I worked
on and off for a couple of weeks on the
show and it was a big deal for me the
cinematographer was extraordinary man
who had shot all of the Godfather movies
and was just a legend so I remembered
it's such an iconic scene because what
Allan looks out the window and he sees
you in the other train and it's this one
of the most memorable scenes from the
movie and I thought that is every extras
dream big just to be sitting there and
someone didn't show we need someone to
play this iconic part you yeah and then
it happens that's absolutely amazing it
was and it was like that it was really
like like those stories where you get
discovered in a drugstore right it was
that just astonishment and they were so
kind to me